be satisfied with what you have read I'm
like no no I want to be a star I want to
be rich mom I'm gonna be rich one day
stop all poverty behavior poverty is a
terrible thing
Cindy you can't work on a Sunday okay
are you and you've got people around you
telling you not to work with sin oh we
have to have a little life balance dude
how can you have life balance when you
broke one ass or get a mentor what's up
beliefs nation at seven I believe in you
and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
today let's learn from one of the best
grant cardone and some of his best
advice on achieving success mentor me
grant also if you want to know a grant
cardone and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where everything
for the next two hundred and fifty four
days I will send you a morning video for
free to help you build your confidence
the link to join is in the description
below you have to go build
self-confidence
[Music]
you
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one sync big the job of mother is to
protect the kid okay and I'm like no I'm
gonna be famous one day the mother says
don't talk to strangers I want to talk
to everybody i watch my dad talk to
everybody I want to have friends all
over the world my mom's like no no no no
don't get too much attention too much
attention could get us in trouble I
wanted to be famous be satisfied with
what you have brand I'm like no no I
want to be a star I want to be rich mom
I'm gonna be rich one day see when
you're when you're 10 years old 15 years
old you're taking in information I'm
watching James Bond I'm like that's the
guy one of them I'm watching the
gangster he's got control that's the guy
I wanted it and in our society you can't
tell people you want to be James Bond
you can't tell people you want to be
rich you can't tell people you want to
be the next Bond oh you can't tell
people you want to be you want your face
on the side of a bus or on a billboard
because they're like what are you
talking about man be happy that you have
to good help be happy that your family
loves you I have two beautiful kids
today two beautiful kids and a wife okay
and my wife understands that I would not
be satisfied with just a great marriage
and two beautiful kids you can't tell
people that someone will hear me say
that and say dude be grateful for what
you have you have health good health
you're not using drugs today you got a
beautiful wife and two beautiful kids
it's not another man
it has never been enough for me in our
society we cannot tell people I want
more I've always wanted 10 times and I
want you to have 10 times more cuz
what's gonna happen is some of what you
have is going to be taken away from you
this planet the planet we live on takes
things from people things go away
cycles in money moves ok health leaves
you aged happens things change I watch
entire industries get destroyed the
great companies have a life of about 50
or 60 years they go away that lifespan
might start changing to twenty or thirty
years or ten years entire industries get
wiped out because people underestimate
what it takes to be successful what it
takes to take care of their family see
this is what I learned when I was 10
years old my dad worked everyday to take
care of his family
good family middle-class family had a
house had the food had a little bit of
life insurance money it wasn't enough if
it was enough why did my mom have to
sell the dream house the next day
why was my waton why was my mom why was
my mom terrified when she should have
been having grief she couldn't she was
instilled with fear how am I gonna take
care of five kids I'm gonna put five
kids through school this is what our
culture is dealing with today people
that are scared seventy six percent of
all Americans live paycheck to paycheck
why because they didn't think about it
I need to multiply everything I think I
need ten times rule number two stopped
all poverty behavior number two stop all
poverty behavior poverty is a terrible
thing if you've ever known anybody lived
in poverty suffer with poverty even
close to the poverty line you know that
it is awful and even those with money
can live like they are in poverty I've
known millionaires that acted like they
were in poverty wouldn't spend any of
the money they had because they were
worried about money not coming in in the
future make a list of all the actions
because most of this is mental make a
list of all action
those who live in poverty operate with
and commit to not doing them listen what
I'm saying here make a list of the
activities that people that either live
in poverty or act like they're living in
poverty how they operate everyday drugs
alcohol buying stuff not investing but
spending wasting weekend's government or
any kind of dependence upon others
shortcuts victim mentality not reading
refusing the network and refusing to get
outside your zip code and travel or all
things that you need to stop and I'm
sure you could expand this list stop all
poverty behavior rule number three work
on yourself I've been busted broke the
beat up I've been I've been at a point
in my life where I thought I thought
less than me then anyone thought of me
how many have been there how do I get
the right girl the right family the
right money the right company the right
employees I don't even like me unlike
what happened to me man what happened I
had more money when I was eight then
when I was 25 the hell happened
I like myself more when I was six years
old then I was 20 25 years old
what happened to me now if you look at
me today six years old in 57 dude I'm
kind of digging myself right now
I like Who I am man I've spent the last
years just doing one thing dude working
on Who I am number one most important
thing Warren Buffett says and I study a
lot of people okay this year I'll
probably spend this year between mentors
what's really my mentor is just the guys
to hook up he says he'll come me up with
other players 20 mentors I don't think I
say too word write a books courses I'll
go off for three weeks and just do a
course you guys worry about a weekend I
can't get away for a weekend did I go
for three weeks and just do courses I'll
probably spend 400 grand this year I'm
worth it man
how am I not worth 400 grand look you
worried about 400 grand how you gonna
get 400 million see see you and I were
brought up to worry about what this
what's in your pocket right I mean I
used to squeeze the quarter so hard it
fly and scream look look everybody
worries about this right whose money is
this somebody else's money man they say
my money rule number four be obsessed I
hear a lot of guys saying right now like
hey only do the things you want to do
dude I do stuff I don't want to do every
single day okay so I don't know who
these people are that don't do the
things they don't want to do maybe they
were given a business or something but
I'm gonna tell you something man if you
don't do the things you don't want to do
you're not gonna grow your business you
won't keep your business I'm telling you
you have to be willing to do you got to
be so obsessed that you don't plant care
see an obsessed person doesn't care if
they have to clean a toilet uh-huh you
know an obsessed person doesn't care if
they if they don't like that activity
but they have to do it you're obsessed
you're in it you do it anyway no matter
what I remember my mom told me one day
she's like you know grant I love you
just the way you are
cuz I still I'm telling her about all
these dreams I have as a child right
yeah and I was reminded when my sister
told me like 30 years later you know
grant you've done a lot we love you just
the way you are and I'm like dude I
wonder how many times I've been told
that you know and and the fact is so
what they love me just the way I am I
don't I don't love me just the way I am
which opens up to this whole field of
people that's like just love yourself
the way you are look if you're broke
you're not living on purpose you don't
like your job you can't get away from
your job dude if you're stuck in a house
you don't like why would you want to
love that you should become obsessed
with hating it man it's obsessed or
average one of the two so pick just pick
get a t-shirt obsessed or get another
t-shirt average which one would you be
more proud wearing right yeah who do I
want to be man who do I want to be how
do i how do I want to die man I want to
die all in and rule number five the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
make sacrifices you guys that take days
off it's my day off
yeah entitled to a day off well why do
you think you should have Wednesday's
off for Thursday sir or you can't work
Saturdays or Sunday Sunday you can't
work on a Sunday okay are you and you've
got people around you telling you not to
work on son oh we have to have a little
life balance dude how can you have life
balance when you broke how can you have
life balance at a holiday in when the
people next door keep you up all night
and ain't light balance that's not even
a vacation right the whole trip how many
been on the trip you did the budget trip
included the free breakfast you did it
on miles and you wish you didn't even go
how many been on that trip before maybe
you don't do the trip maybe you're not
entitled to a trip this year maybe
you're not ready to trip that's what
Elena and I did for 10 years the
sacrifice the sacrifice today we'll
sacrifice this week we'll sacrifice this
month we'll sacrifice
this year we'll sacrifice so one day
maybe we don't have to compromise every
week we talk about our finances what do
we do this week how much do we make
where are we going what are we spending
okay the moment I say hey no more
jackets no more bus stop it she'll stop
it so that we can one day we can one day
spend whatever we want okay there there
there is should come a time where you
guys should be able to spend whatever
you want but most people are spending
what they can't afford now a landline
that later they can have you have any on
how to make their money multiply and
most people don't understand there is a
sacrifice space we went through the
sacrifice phase where there was years of
just cut off every and we weren't saving
them for now you know here for the
rainbow that's right y'all need to save
for the rainbow I mean it you see we
didn't go on a vacation for 13 years
yeah I've been saving for this stuff I I
wasn't saving for vacations I was saving
so I could Bank into real estate so I
could go to sleep at night and even if I
had a bad night of sleep and had to get
up three or four times I'm like dying
I'm making money in my sleep even if I'm
not happy I'm like I'm making money in
my sleep and hoozy that's the goal yeah
you and your wife need to have let's
make money when we go to Turks and
Caicos when we go to st. Barts when we
go to Cali
let's go waste some money later in our
life maybe you say hey I'm gonna
sacrifice today so I don't have to
compromise in the future now I've got a
special bonus cut from grant on how to
surround yourself with success that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
is time for the three point landing
questions time to move from just
watching another video to taking action
in your life for business and if you're
feeling bold leave your answers in the
comments below here we go question
number one what does thinking bigger on
your goals look like for you number two
what poverty behavior do you mean to SAP
and number three where do you need to
most work on yourself so you know every
time I'm having trouble every time I'm
like man I don't think I can get to
where I'm going I just started looking
at the top I don't look at the bad facts
all I do is I start searching tell me
about wealthy people facts about wealthy
people anything what are they doing what
do they buy it just gets me out of my
problem right it gets me to think
you know the first plane I bought I
bought this plane because I saw other
wealthy people making moves I'm not an
irresponsible person okay like I've
always been a very frugal person but the
frugal was hurting me not helping me
your network is your net worth how rich
you can get has something to do with who
you're hanging with how rich you can
think has something to do with you who
you're hanging with okay how smart you
are has something to do with your
surroundings if you hang out with dumb
people you go end up dumb if you hang
out with junkies you're gonna end up
being a junkie you hang out with
criminals I'm not talking about two
people to go to jail I'm talking about
all the people it's your office right
now they cheat their employer and cheat
themselves you hang out with creme
crimps you end up being a Crim
if you want to build a network number
one thing commit to building a network a
network by definition is not if you're
building a new it network is not the
people you're already with it's how do I
add people to my network so number one
you've got to commit to building a
network number two who do you want in
the network who is it
most of you just go for more people like
you have already in your network I want
new people new characters new
personalities new thinking new ideas the
old adage if you're the smartest person
in the room you in the wrong room and
number three when you start building
this network up and you start meeting
the people okay
number two is who do you want to meet
who who you an add to the Met Network
you go 9,000 people in a room you don't
need to meet all 9,000 you need to meet
maybe a list of 30 or 40 people who do
you want to meet number three when you
meet them focus on them not on you it
shouldn't be here's my card
I'm a chiropractor this is what I do can
I give you an adjustment it it should be
like who are you how can I help you what
are you doing where do you live okay
what projects are you working on how can
I help you
if you want more and cardolan took at
the top 50 rules video made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there so you don't get
attention today you have absolutely zero
chance of being successful money follows
attention period